We have observed in the simple
example from the previous clip
that when the Markov chain
initially starts in state one,
the probability that it
finds itself in state one
after a long period of time
converges to a constant value,
in our case, 2/7.
In addition, if the Markov chain
initially starts in state two,
the probability that it
finds itself in state one
after a long period
of time also converges
to the same constant value, 2/7.
Are these two properties
of long term convergence
and of vanishing effect
of the initial state
over the long term
convergence always true?
Mathematically, we are asking
the question, is rij of n pi j
when n goes to infinity?
The answer is that for
nice Markov chains,
this will be true, but
this is not always true.
Consider the first question.
Does rij(n) always
converge to something
as n goes to infinity?
Look at the following
simple Markov chain.
When in state two, you
will never be in state two
at the next transition.
You will end up next in either
state one or state three.
However, no matter
where you end up,
you're sure that the next
transition will bring you back
to state two, either
here or from here.
In other words, for n odd,
r22 of n will always be 0,
and for n even, r22
of n will always be 1.
And so r22 of n
will never converge.
It will always alternate
between 1 or 0.
Convergence has failed.
That chain has a
periodic structure,
and we will see in
the next lecture
that if periodicity is
absent from a chain,
then we don't have a
problem with convergence.
Consider now the second question
dealing with a vanishing
importance of initial states
when convergence occurs.
For this, consider the
following Markov chain.
If you start in state one,
there is no way you can escape.
You are certain to
stay there forever.
So r11 of n will always be 1.
On the other hand, if
you start in state three,
there is no way you will
ever reach state one.
So r31 of n will be 0.
The initial state
of where you started
does matter in this example,
and its influence never
vanishes in the long run.
The second nice property
has failed here.
And here, this has to do
with the Markov structure
where some states are not
accessible from some other
states, and we will address
this in the final portion
of this lecture.
Finally, let us calculate
r21 of n for large n.
So you start in state
two, and you ask yourself,
what is the probability that
I will end up in state one
after n steps for n large?
Well, when you start in two,
you may stay in two for a while
by doing this kind of
transition and this transition
and this transition.
But eventually, with probability
one, you will escape.
Either you will go
to state one, or you
will escape to state three.
And in that case, you
will never go back to two.
If you are in one, you will
never go back here to two,
and from three, you will
never go back to two.
Because of the symmetry
between these probabilities
here-- 0.3 on this side
and 0.3 on this side--
when you do escape
state two, you
are equally likely to escape
toward one or toward three.
So what you have is that
r21 of n will be 1/2.